here's what would happen if you knew  what would happen over the next 100  years  well you can't exactly predict the  future but you can make educated guesses  by the year 2025 you'd see how India  surpassed China to become the most  populated country in the world India's  population would grow to over 1.4  billion people jumping ahead to the year  2050 you'd find that robots have taken  over many of our jobs they'd be running  our hospitals transportation and  security by the year 2016 global  temperatures would increase by over  three degrees if you lived on the  coastline you'd see your home devastated  by rising sea levels and intense storms  finally at the end of your journey  through the future in the year 2122  you'd reach the point where you could  upload your mind to a computer so